[Music]
foreign
so here in this video we will analyze
the anatomy and biology of shin Godzilla
a version of the Gmail that was seen in
the 2016 movie of the same name and was
made by Toho here we will discuss all
the organ systems and their evolution in
all the four forms including the
cellular makeup its digestive system its
respiratory and nuclear system just to
name a few so let's get to it
let's start with premutation Biology
Godzilla was described as an ancient sea
creature that becomes entwined with
Humanity's nuclear activities in the
1950s nuclear waste discarded into the
ocean mainly by the United States gives
rise to this aquatic being described as
a prehistoric Marine reptile still alive
at that time its encounter with
radiation triggers and astonishingly
rapid and radical process of evolution
which spans several decades this
Evolution equips the creature with
specialized traits including formidable
Claws and fans that enabled it to feed
on more radioactive material like
submerged canisters of nuclear waste the
creature's entire existence and Falls
beneath the ocean's surface and after 60
years of evolution the creature
transitions from sea to land
transforming into the colossal and
destructive Godzilla
now let's look at Godzilla it's body
design first the initial form of
Godzilla is introduced as an aquatic
creature resembling a large an unusual
marine animal in this stage the first
form is mostly submerged underwater and
moves with a serpentine motion the
second station marks its transition into
land gaining legs that enable it to
crawl on Shore yet its movement remains
awkward and unsteady due to its rapid
transition and that the entire body
hasn't adapted yet a tutorial
environment he was also bleeding all
over especially from his gills probably
due to the rapid changing organs inside
of him the third form stands more a
bright resembling the traditional
upright posture of the classic Godzilla
its limbs are more developed now
allowing it to support its massive frame
more effectively the fourth form is
significantly larger and more powerful
than the previous ones it fully Embraces
the classic Godzilla appearance with a
massive body dorsal placed along its
back and an imposing upright posture
so the first form which would have been
the first visible form of shin Godzilla
is fully aquatic although there could
have been numerous other forms in the 60
years of Rapid Evolution the second one
is somewhat amphibious trying to survive
the atmosphere sunlight UV rays and
basically a new environment the third
and fourth forms can survive underwater
and are also fully terrestrial at the
same time the first form is 14 meters
long then 28 meters tall in the second
form followed by 57 meters in the third
form and 118 meters in the fourth and
biggest form the skin texture seems to
appear rough and uneven seeming to look
like wounds and clotted blood in the
later third and fourth forms while
looking at sickly yellow in the second
and first forms Shin Godzilla has
digitigrated legs small hands a small
bulbous head and an overall reptile
amphibian appearance and these seems to
hold true for all three forms except for
the first one
so now let's get to the skeletal system
of shin Godzilla since it began as an
unknown life form that was mutated and
evolved rapidly on the ocean floor this
would mean that the creature would have
had either a cartilaginous or
calcium-based bony skeleton in a very
great artwork although not canon as it
should be it's fan art we can clearly
see how the bones and skeletal structure
of shin Godzilla would be if it was ever
visible to us
it would have appeared to be a saurian
with a long Serpentine vertebral column
that extends from the head to the tail
there would be also a rib cage ending in
a large very enlarged sternum on the
chest as well as Bones on the dorsal
plates I don't know about you but I'm
considering this as Canon at least head
Cannon and also the bones would be super
dense and made out of a different
allotrope having a powerful structure
for Atomic bonds to be able to hold the
weight of 92 000 tons as in the fourth
form
so after discussing the body design and
the skeleton let's take a look at what
Godzilla is actually made up of his
cells in the movie after the U.S dropped
bombs on Shin's back pieces of his flesh
splatter all over the ground and when
researchers were analyzed they found
that the cells of shin Godzilla were
unlike any other they were extremophilic
cells and they classified Godzilla as a
multicellular colony of extremophiles
functioning together as an organism with
a central nervous system these cells are
hard enough to withstand nuclear energy
extreme heat and radiation extremophiles
are organisms that have evolved to live
under extreme circumstances and that's
what Godzilla is in essence an entity
composed of trillions of Hardy cells
working in unison to adapt to an
ever-changing environment also to
threats and circumstances
so moving on he doesn't really have a
digestive system per se although he
still has a mouth teeth and a crude
Elementary Canal he has no need to feed
he would have required those when he was
an aquatic reptile feeding off of
radioactive waste but later in the
second stage onwards we never really saw
him in just anything which shows that
the head mouth and teeth have all stayed
in place as either vestigial organs or
as defense mechanisms the latter which
holds more truth as Godzilla could bite
and jump on targets his eyes would be
needed to spot threads and lastly his
mouth is essential for the atomic breath
and a thermal flame to come out of so
funny enough the mouth has evolved from
ingesting taking food in to excretion
you know to breathe the atomic laser
now what about the respiratory system
okay let's take you back to Elementary
science respiration doesn't really mean
just breathing in and out it's taking in
a required external material in order to
oxidize food and release energy for
metabolism so in the case of shin
Godzilla he initially was a marine
animal a sea reptile meaning that he
would have been breathing air with lungs
with a radioactive mutation he gradually
stayed underwater and developed gills
which persisted under the later forms in
the second form his gills were bleeding
profusely as it started to adapt to air
a different environment as the third
form emerged it would seem that the
Redevelopment of lungs had been
successful although he did return back
to the sea but that's not because he was
unable to breathe properly it was due to
the changing respiratory system that now
encompasses the nuclear reaction system
in full he needed water to help his
blood cool down his overheating body and
now from that let's get to the best part
now let's get to Shin Godzilla's
internal nuclear system this organ
system is theorized to be a set of
specialized organs within Shin
Godzilla's body that are capable of
absorbing storing and utilizing
radiation these organs allow Godzilla to
feed on nuclear material including
radioactive waste and convert it into
energy which is true as they did mention
the early premutated form to be able to
eat radioactive waves this system serves
as a unique energy source for Godzilla
it enables the creature to power its
various physiological processes
including its rapid regeneration and
adaptation this concept aligns with the
film's overarching themes of the
consequences of nuclear energy and its
impact on the environment it also likely
contributes to Godzilla's remarkable
regenerative abilities radiation
exposure might accelerate tissue repair
and regeneration allowing Godzilla to
hear rapidly from injuries sustained
during battles
so while most multicellular organisms
depend on energy released by the
breakdown of ATP adenosine triphosphate
Godzilla relies solely on energy
released from fission of an undescribed
element or compound maybe it's water
maybe it's uranium maybe it's something
else this nuclear reaction inside his
body is a heavily regulated one as any
increase or overdrive would lead to a
catastrophic meltdown as we can see him
going back to the water after evolving
to the third form since he was
overheating and needed to cool down and
again after he used the atomic breath as
well as the dorsal lasers for defense he
had to become dominant to allow his
unique blood to cool down his chain
reaction the chain reaction of the
elements inside his body his blood as
well is very peculiar as it does seem to
act as a car coolant instead of the
normal nutrient delivery mechanism also
it was stated that the nuclear reaction
inside Godzilla's body generated a new
unknown element or an isotope that
wasn't in the periodic table
now let's talk about the other weird
parts of the strange Godzilla that isn't
present elsewhere for example his
nuclear organ system he does have
another thing an energy dissipation
system which were his dorsal plates for
air Cooling and his blood acting as a
coolant liquid also it still is very
long super long which also had dorsal
plates lining its top till the end of it
with the end seeming like another head
possessing weird facial features and can
shoot the laser and in the end of the
movie it began to sprout out different
fifth forms which appeared humanoid and
were smaller still large relative to us
though 15 meters or 50 feet in height
the tail like the mouth and the dorsal
plates can shoot the atomic breath in
laser form as well and interestingly
Godzilla would close his eyes behind a
silver nictating membrane when he
performs this attack showing a very
complex correlation and integration of
the organ systems in his body
it was also stated that Godzilla here
probably had a phased array radar method
of detecting threats or locations just
like jet fighters or radar stations as
is evident when the drones got shut out
instantly when they came near to his
dormant body he displays the remarkable
ability to adapt his physical form and
attack methods based on his adversaries
and momentary needs the remarkable skill
is facilitated by his genetic
information which far surpasses human
genetic complexity by Eightfold moreover
the acquired combat abilities based on
the atomic energy initially seen as his
Atomic breath was very very peculiar
even while recharging Godzilla develop
an ESP likability functioning as the
earlier set phase array radar to fend
off nearby threads these unique
attributes showcases Shin Godzilla's
exceptional adaptability and versatility
and given enough time he would have
evolved into 6th the seventh and the
eighth God form as well
so in summary Shin Godzilla is a fast
evolving multicellular Colony creature
caused by irradiation of an aquatic
reptile he became a monster with a bony
skeleton with Hardy extremophile cells
trillions of them a nuclear organ system
that powers his adaptations and needs
his metabolism and also he has defunct
normal organ systems he can evolve to
suit any environment and also to counter
any threat and would eventually take
over the world so that's about it I hope
you have enjoyed watching this video on
the biology and anatomy of shin Godzilla
do hit the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates and new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam